can you tell us about the 20 people in a
cabin for many days yeah so our casa
crew was 15 people we stayed in a cabin
for 20 days Chris and I lived in a
Motorhome the motorhome you see in the
film which we did not have
air-conditioning really cold at night
really hot during this case yes but we
wanted we feel like as directors we need
to suffer the most like that's you know
when you're asking people to do things
for not a livable wage you need to
sacrifice the most so it was great it
was literally I purposely hand-picked
every single person on that crew to make
sure that they work as a team as well as
their own individual what they bring
individually because I knew it was tight
quarters and they got to live together
and I don't want you know assaults and
you know the LA riots to happen in the
cabin so um so it was great like we
didn't have I think the longest day we
had was 10 hours then people didn't have
to commute home all the times I stayed
there so it was a lot of like the cast
and crew going river rafting every
afternoon after we wrapped and our
caterer he cooked three meals a day plus
snacks so that food was always taken
care of and it's just really good about
creating that really great summer camp
environment where it's fun because we're
doing a really heavy film and it's
really hard to shoot sometimes it's a
disintegrating marriage and it's
emotional and and so you just have to
make it the levity happen outside of
that especially when you're making I
don't think I would ever have my cassock
robe live on set ever know it sounded
like a great idea and to save money and
that sort of thing it's too hard it's
when you don't have a place to release
and go especially I mean especially for
all evac actors it's like so their
bedroom that their characters you know
yeah yeah living it yeah we won't be
doing that again um I don't do that no
makers don't and no matter how much
money insane don't do it to get over how
get a hotel that's opsite yeah no yeah
so I think that's that was the biggest
mistake that we learned while they
totally they made the best of it like
for sure yeah um it just I wouldn't do
that time one I mean they were great too
because it was like you know they sort
of self-medicated with these river
rafting trips every day and they would
just catch crew be like or I'm gonna one
day off that way to turn around from
nights today's but literally our caterer
organized a camping trip so it took
everybody and they went camping for a
night to get off and without us so that
we had time because that's when were
directors and so we try to you know have
boundaries and you know I mean I love
every single person dearly on my cast
and crew by the same time you got to be
careful of that relationship when you're
you know when you're directing and so we
tend to pull away a little bit just that
we need to be our units plus you know
they need to about it logically
yeah will you be around yeah they went
on a camping trip for a day and it gave
us the cabin by ourselves for a day and
we were just able to really relax and
and how much that living environment
impact what we see on the screen one
hundred percent I mean because it really
that cabins of character and I think it
really while it was hard for the actors
it really put them in the space as well
so while I wouldn't do it again because
I think they could get there without
that yes um because I trust my actors
and getting there without that at the
same time it did it did it did you do
see you see that dread a little bit of a
drag on
which is
you know I can't help but ask what was
your like your favorite or your best
moment working on this film yeah well
there I mean it's not it wasn't a fun
moment but there was a there was a scene
that comes toward the end of the film
and the one of the characters asked the
other character did you ever think we'd
be these people and then the mail the
world character Ernie responds no I did
not and when he said that line there was
something about his delivery that this
is not hyperbole this is literally what
happened we're watching a monitor and
both of us at the exact same moment
burst into tears and it aiming it hurt
and it was like it was painful but at
that moment I was like wow this might
mean that we have something good because
you know it was I'm its own completely
spontaneous unsynchronized a sobbing
session because of one line of dialogue
I mean testament to his performance that
I've done really good but yeah I think
that was probably my favorite moment
because I just I was like wow this this
might work for me which is an actual a
little more fun oh that's good moment
but so there is a when the to the couple
come in and the bag of on characters
come in they take him on this little
adventure and it involves breaking into
a to a summer camp and having to sneak
past the camp directors house and not
only did we it was fun to have Wonder
and Mark kind of come in because if
anyone knows wonder and Mark they're
both just these beams of light and
energy and happiness you know and
there's such carries I just wondering um
both fell gorlo it out on set we shot
slow-motion footage of Falkor chasing a
ball like as yours but um it was at the
YMCA and a camp director catches them
and the four of them have to run through
the woods to get away and so literally
the DP has to run you know with the
camera following them
I just decided I think we all just
decided to just run with them you know
and just have it be this like we're
literally running with it to see if we
could and it was just so much fun it was
just such a fun moment and I that whole
sequence I can't help but smile so big
when i watch everything cuz the
characters are having so much fun yeah
and actually was really funny last night
in the premier like a guy had like it up
and go to the bathroom like right when
that sequence started I'm like no you're
missing the only fun part so it's just
this is when you when you get I just I
just love feeling the energy that
emotions of the characters you know
whether that be good or bad you know
it's just it's big
you